let's head to china now which is racing
to track a copper 19 outbreak that may
have been spreading in the capital for a
week beijing residents have been rushing
to buy essential items and can amid
concerns that a widespread lockdown
could be imposed let's go to katrina
younow who's live for us in beijing
hello there katrina we've witnessed the
fallout from that really strict lockdown
in shanghai what's been the reaction
from beijing residents that they could
be next
hi emily well people here people here in
beijing are extremely anxious and
nervous supermarkets across the city
especially in the eastern part have been
stripped of many of their supplies with
people panic buying over the weekend
people think that any day now a lockdown
could be announced and this is because
authorities in the city said that there
were 41 cases reported in chao yang
district which is actually where we are
located in the past few days now 41
doesn't sound like a very big number but
they say that the situation is
particularly concerning because these
cases have been they say spreading
silently throughout the capital over the
past week and because of this we've seen
28 neighborhoods put under lockdown
that's at least 20 000 people confined
to their homes
1200 have been identified as close
contacts and they were swiftly moved to
quarantine centers for isolation now
authorities say that they're going to
conduct three rounds of mass testing in
chao young district
this week that's about five million
people who have to be tested three times
over the next few days and they've also
discouraged any form of travel in and
out of the city
especially with the upcoming may public
holiday which starts on sunday which
goes for about four days and is really
typically when a lot of families leave
the city for travel
indeed and what's the latest out of
shanghai how are authorities continuing
to implement that zero tolerance policy
well shanghai remains the epicenter of
the a virus outbreak here in china they
had 17
500 cases reported on monday which is
slightly down from the numbers that we
were seeing last week which were between
20 000 to 25 000 every day but it's a
still very severe situation as far as
the authorities are concerned and when
it comes to zero tolerance well if you
are lucky enough in shanghai to live in
a neighborhood where they have not had
any new covert cases for
one or two weeks you might be given the
freedom to leave your home to leave your
neighborhood wander around go get some
groceries for a few hours
but the majority of those living in the
commercial center of china that's 25
million people the majority of them are
still under some form of very strict
lockdown either confined to their homes
or confined to their residential
compounds
authorities say from this current
outbreak in shanghai we've had about 138
deaths which is very high for china for
one place since the beginning of the
pandemic we haven't seen that kind of
number most of these deaths they say
were elderly people who were
unvaccinated now the good thing about
shanghai is that we are not seeing today
the kind of complaints around access to
food and other essential supplies
logistics chains seem to have improved
in the city so that is a very good thing
but still residents are enormously
frustrated we have to remember some of
them have been confined to their homes
since the end of march and there is no
end date for this lockdown and experts
are predicting based on these current
numbers it may not end until the
beginning of the middle of may
just extraordinary thank you very much
for that update katrina especially given
that the pandemic happened you know two
years ago in china all right